["Take Me By Your Side"]
Guys, welcome to the setup.
I wanna talk about what the setup actually is.
Okay, first of all, most people,
when they train you sales,
no matter what sales training you go into,
no matter who you talk to,
most people just train you to wait for the objection
and then how to overcome that objection
or how to try to overcome that objection.
For example, when the customer says,
I wanna think about it, you say this.
When the customer says I need to talk to my spouse,
you say that, okay?
And that's exactly how I was trained.
But I realized that they're testing
a couple of different things
and just trial and error,
that the times when I brought up the objection first,
it always seemed to be a non-objection
when I got to the closing table, okay?
And I learned this very early on.
And so I wanna relate this to,
if you have kids or just think back to when you were a kid,
and I'm guessing this is probably the situation.
But for me, for example, if my kid does something stupid,
first of all, I'm gonna be mad no matter what, right?
But if I find out from their own mouth,
they come to me and say, hey dad, look man,
I broke the iPad, I'm gonna be ticked, right?
But I'm gonna be a lot less ticked
than if I just find a broken iPad lying on the ground.
So it's the same exact thing.
We know the objections are gonna come
and we're never gonna be able to avoid them,
whether it's now, whether it's later,
the objections will always come.
So why don't we just go and meet the objection?
Why don't we just offensively go meet the objection,
overcome them all in the setup phase
so that we don't have to deal with objections?
That's an interesting way to think about it, right?
And so I've heard something along the lines of,
and I've heard this from multiple people,
it's like the better your questions are,
the better the results that you're gonna get.
Something, I think I know I butchered that,
but whatever, you get the point, right?
And so instead of asking how do I overcome
I wanna think about it,
let's start asking how do we just avoid objections
or how do we just not have objections
during the Zoom close?
Well, I found a way and that is
we're gonna meet the objections head on
and we're gonna overcome them before they even come up.
So the setup, just to define it,
is the period from the moment you call and do the hook
until the moment you jump on the Zoom close
and do the close, okay?
During that entire period, that is the setup.
So guys, the close should and actually does happen
during the setup for a couple of reasons, okay?
And it should happen for a couple of reasons
during this period.
Number one is that it's not expected.
Everyone expects you to get on the Zoom close
and to have your spiel and get to the end
and do the hard close and have all these sales techniques,
but what they don't expect is to be closed
during these initial calls.
They don't expect to be closed during that initial hook.
They don't expect to be closed during a screencast.
They don't even know what a screencast is, right?
So they definitely don't expect it.
So number one is they don't expect
to be closed during this period.
The next thing is the business owner has their guard down
during this period, okay?
When they get on the Zoom close, make no mistake,
they're expecting to be sold,
they're expecting to be pitched something,
but during this phase, they're really open,
they're casual, they just don't expect it.
They're watching a screencast
and they're not expecting to be closed, okay?
And so without them even knowing,
we are overcoming objections in our conversations
on the phone and our text messages during our screencast,
they don't even realize it, okay?
And the last thing is what I love about this,
and this is why the deal should be closed during this phase,
is this is gonna take the pressure off of that last call.
That last call should be enjoyable.
Last call should be quick and easy and breezy,
and it should just be a matter of you getting
the credit card and you guys getting excited
about working together, okay?
So it's going to take the pressure
off of that big, scary, hard close,
and that is why it should be,
that is why the close should happen during the setup.
The objective of the setup, very, very, very simple, okay?
The objective is one thing, and that is to overcome
all the objections that you could potentially have
or that you know you will potentially have during this step.
And then we're gonna do it strategically,
we're gonna do it so it just makes sense,
there's no pressure, that's it.
The objective of this step is that we are going
to overcome all the objections offensively,
or what they used to teach me this word,
I don't even know if this is a word,
but we used to use the word preemptively,
meaning before it actually comes up.
The goal, the objective, is very simple.
Overcome the objections before they ever become objections.